[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ملفات الخامسه من
العربيه والبدايه هو كالمعتاد بابرز
العناوين
دقائق وتفصلنا عن افتتاح اول مونديال في
بلد عربيه قطر 20 22
تدميرها 89 هدفا في غارات جويه شمال سوريا
والعراق وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تتواعد
بالرد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وسط دعوات لاغاثه المحتاجين في مهابات
الايرانيه النظام الايرانيه ينشر تعزيزات
واسلحه ثقيله في المدينه
بالعوده للمن وارتفاعه حاد بعدد متابعي
ترامب في تويتر بعد اعاده تفعيل حسابه
اهلا بكم بعد دقائق قليله من الان يشهد
ملعب البيت في العاصمه القطريه الدوحه بعد
قليل حفل افتتاح كاس العالم الملعب الواقع
على بعد ستينه كيلومترا شمال الدوحه ينتظر
ان يستقطب 60,000 متفرج ومن المقرر ان
يشارك في حفل الافتتاح الفنان الكوري
الجنوبيه
عضو فريق البي تي اس كما يشارك في الحفل
روبي ويليامز ومريم فارس
الى ذلك وجها ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان جميع الوزارات والهيئات
والجهات الحكوميه في المملكه بتقديم اي
دعم اضافيه او تسهيلات تحتاج اليها دوله
قطر لمسانده جهودها في استضافه بطوله كاس
العالم 20 22 في قطر ووجه الامير محمد بن
سلمان وزير الرياضه الامير عبد العزيز بن
تركي الفيصل بمتابعه هذا الامر
بالطبع سنكون معكم دوما ويوميا على شاشه
العربيه مع الكاس على العربيه وللحديث
اكثر حول افتتاح كاس العالم تنضم الينا
زميلتي لليان تنوري مرحبا بك لليان نحن
امام الحدث الرياضي الابرز في العالم وهذا
العام هو على ارض العربيه في قطر الشقيقه
شكرا لك رشا بالفعل نحن ننتظر هذا الحفل
بفارغ الصبر طبعا هو همم اهميته انه تقام
للمره الاولى على ارض عربيه للمره الاولى
في الشرق الاوسط ننتظر هذا الحفل كل اربع
سنوات مباراه همم من هذا نوع افتتاح من
هذا النوع همم من المتوقع ان يشهده حواله
مليار شخص كما ذكرت همم رشا وكما شاهد
طبعا
المتابعون انه تتوافق كبار الشخصيات منهم
همم العهد السعودي الرئيس السيسي ايضا
كبار الشخصيات من حول العالم
يتواجدون في حفله الافتتاح تمت الدعوات من
الدوحه الكثير من الشخصيات كان من
الشخصيات الفنيه او الرسميه
لهذا الحفل الذي ياتي بعده مباشره تاتي
بعده تنطلق بعضه مباشره ال مباراه
الافتتاحيه بين قطر همم الدوله المضيفه
بين منتخب اكوادور طبعا همم الرساله التي
وجهها رئيس الاتحاد فيفا والتي قال فيها
اليوم انه ستكون في حفل الافتتاح الكثير
من المفاجات غير التي ذكرناها غير التي
نعرفها ولم تتسرب اي معلومه نهائيا عن هذا
الحفل همم طبعا هو كل نسخه تكون هناك همم
هكذا تعليقات او هكذا امور يعني حتى
العالم تشاهد
وتنتظر ب- همم فارغ الصبر طبعا الرساله هي
الرساله الانسانيه رساله همم الكوره هي
للجميع ثعلب من الجميع متابعه همم الكره
والاستمتاع بالمنافسات وهمم نسيان كل ما
هو همم حول نعم صحيح لليان تعرفين منذ
اقامه هذه البطوله منذ عام 1930 لن تتوقف
بطوله كاس العالم الا مرتين فقط بسبب
الحرب العالميه الاولى والثانيه 42
و46 شكرا لك لليان سنعود لك بعد قليل
حينما يكون الافتتاح قد بدا بالفعل وسنكون
معك يوميا ومع فريق العربي على الشاشه في
الكاس على العربيه شكرا يا باشا
والى ملفات الخامسه في مستجدات العمليه
التركيه في شمال العراق وشمال سوريا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع تركيا تدميرا 89 هدفا في
ضربات جويه وقال وزير الدفاع فلوسي اكار
ان الغارات الجويه كانت ضروريه وان تخطيط
لها كان دقيقا وحساسا على حد قوله
في هذا السياق العمليه التي نفذت ضد اهداف
الارهابيه في شمال العراق وشمال سوريا منذ
منتصف ليل هذا المساء تم التخطيط لها
بحساسيه ولحسن الحظ كما تنفيذها بنجاح
بالمقابل قالت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
انها سترد في الوقت والمكان المناسبين على
القصف التركي على شمالي سوريا وكانت
الاداره الذاتيه لشمال وشاق سوريا اتهمت
سياسه تركيا بالفشل قائله انها تفجير
اسطنبول ما هو الا ذريعه لتبرير هجومها في
الخارج تماما كمستهدفت عده مناطق شمل شاق
سوريا واضافت الاداره في بيانها ان تركيا
تقصف مركز مدينه عين العرب كوباني وكافه
مناطق شمال وشرق سوريا بالطيران الحربي
بصوره عشوائيه وناشدت المجتمع دولي والدول
الضامنه القيامه بمسؤوليتها لوقف هذا
العدوان وكافه الممارسات لا انسانيه
لتركيا على حد وصف الاداره
هذا واعلنت السلطات السوريه من جهتها مقتل
عدد من الجنود بالهجمات التركيه على رفيع
حلب والحسكه بينما اكد المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان ان عدد القتلى ارتفع الى
واحد وثلاثين شخصا بينهم 12 من قوات
النظام وثمانيه عشر عنصرا من قوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه موضحا ان هناك ما يقارب
الاربعين جريحا نتيجه استهداف جوي من قبل
طائرات حربيه تركيه اضافه الى وجود ما لا
يقل عن 18 عنصر من المفقودين ما بين حلب
والحسكه واشار مدير المرصد السوري الى ان
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اعادت موضع قواتها
خشيه من ضربه تركيه جديده سواء برا او جوا
ونتابع الموقف على الارض ينضم الينا شبكه
مراسل العربيه من اربيل مراسله العربيه
احمد الحمداني ومن اسطنبول لمراس العربيه
زيدان مرحبا بكم الى هذه النشره ابدا من
زيدان زيدان كيف تبدو ردود فعل
الاداره او الحكومه التركيه على التمديدات
بهذا الهجوم على هذه القوات وهذه المناطق
في سوريا
حتى الان اي رد فعل على التصريحات او ردود
الفعل الغربيه على هذا الموضوع او ردود
الفعل بشكل عام على قضيه الضربه الجويه
التي نفذتها هذا اليوم لكن قبل بدء
العمليه العسكريه او نتحدث عن ضربات جويه
قبل بدء الضربات الجويه منذ تفجير شارع
الاستقلال يوم الاحد الماضي كان هناك
انتقاد وتحديدا من وزير الداخليه التركي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه الداعمه لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه على حد تعبيره وقال ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي التي تمول
وتدعم هذا التنظيم الذي فجر في شارع
الاستقلال وادي هذا التفجير الى مقتل
مدنيين كان هناك انتقاد للولايات المتحده
ورفض وزير الداخليه قبول رساله العزاء من
السفاره الامريكيه في انقره لذلك كان هناك
انتقادات لكما ذكرت للدعم الامريكي لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه التي تتهممها انقره بانها
المسؤوله عن هذا الهجوم وانها السوري لحزب
العمال الكردستاني لذلك اليوم القصف كان
على هذه القوات او قيادات هذه القوات
والمناطق والنقاط التي تتواجد فيها هذه
القوات وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في همم
ريف حلب شمال حلف في تل رفعت ومن وايضا في
شرق همم سوريا وشرق الفرات تحديدا في عين
العرب وعين عيسى وعندنا والجزيره وايضا
ديريك كل هذه المناطق طالها القصف التركي
تقريبا 89 نقطه استهدفها القصف التركي همم
منذ الليله الماضيه وحتى صباح هذا اليوم
تقريبا نتحدث عن مرحله اولى همم
اشاره يعني وزاره الدفاع التركيه
واستهدفها على وجه تحديد مقررات قياده
وايضا مخابئ وملاجه ومستودعات ذخيره وقال
البيان التركي ان ااه هذا القصف ادى الى
مقتل عدد من القياديين في التنظيمات التي
وصفها البيان بالارهابيه طبعا في شمال
العراق
مع ايضا القصف المواقع التي اسمها في
العراق اليك احمد
اكثر من 70 ضربه كانت
موجهه على مواقع داخل اقليم كردستان من
قبل طبعا الطائرات او المقاتلات التركيه
همم وان هذه المواقع كانت في في مجملها في
المناطق الشماليه الشرقيه من محافظه اربيل
وهي ما تعرف بسلسله جبال قنديل قنديل هي
على الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه تماما ولا
تبعد كثيرا ايضا عن الحدود العراقيه
التركيه وهي خارج عن سلطه العراقيه منذ
ثلاث عقود يتخذ منها همم جماعات مسلحه
تتبع الى همم حزب العمال الكردستاني ما
قرات وماذات ومنطلق لهم فيها جماتهم همم
منذ ذلك الوقت وحتى الان وتركيا همم همم
استهدفت هذا المعقل كونه الاهم في كل
المواقع الموجوده للبكبكه التركيه في
كردستان وكما قلت لما له من القياده
والسيطره
اكثر من قرى كثيره ومناطق كثيره هي التي
استهدفت همم طبعا همم هناك طبعا بيانات من
جهاز مكافاه الارهاب الكردي انها في اقليم
كردستان قال اكثر من 30 شخص تم همم قتلوا
سقطوا في هذه الهجمات التركيه وان طبعا
هذه الحصيله يبدو انها غير نهائيه كون ان
همم هناك يتوقع ان تكون حصيله اخرى لكن
همم هنا لا بد ان نذكر ان لا جرحى ولا
قتلى البككه حزب العمال كردستاني يصلون
الى مشاكل اربيل ويتلقون العلاج وبالتالي
لا حاصله رسميه من حكومه تقليل كردستان
المنطقه هي منطقه نزاع خارج سيطره
الحكومات سواء كان عراقيه او الكرديه في
اقليم كردستان
ومنطقه مغلقه
ونعتمد فقط على بيانات
المتصارعين في هذه الحرب تركيا وطبعا
همم ولكن الجهاز بالكردي هو الذي اصدر هذه
الحصيله واربعه
هذه الهجمات احمد بالطبع زميلي احمد
الحمداني موصل العربيه من اربيل وكما ذكر
زميلي ايضا زيدان زين كلو حتى اللحظه لا
يبدو الامد العسكري لهذه العمليه متاحا
ربما نشهد مزيد من الضربات ومزيد من القصف
شكرا ايضا موصول لزيدان على هذه التغطيه
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
وانا ابقى معكم مع ملفات الخامسه على
العربيه ولدينا
قصف جديد يستهدف محطه
تتبادلني لاتهامات
وانا نتابع مع حضراتكم ملفات الخامسه الى
اخر تطورات الاحتجاجات في ايران اذا افادت
تقارير للمعارضه الايرانيه بسقوط ضحايا
اثر هجوم الامن الايراني على متظاهرين في
مدينه ده كلام بمحافظه كردستان في غرب
ايران واشارت الى ان ذلك جاء خلال
احتجاجات لاهالي المدينه
واسلحه ثقيله في مدينه مادباد بمحافظه
اذربيجان الغربيه في وقت حلقت مروحيات
الجيش على علو منخفض في سماءها وسط دعوات
بالتحرك لانقاذ المحتاجين
[موسيقى]
وبالرغم من تهديدات النظام الايرانيه بقمع
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه ومطالبه السلطه
القضائيه بمحاكمه من يشارك فيها الا ان
هذه الاحتجاجات طالت نحو 30 مدينه في 18
محافظه خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه نشاهد
التفاصيل
في تحدي اني تحذيرات المرشد الايراني بقمع
الاحتجاجات ومطالبه السلطه القضائيه
بمحاكمتكافه المشاركين في المظاهرات
الشعبيه تتواصل الاحتجاجات في اكثر من 30
مدينه و18 محافظه ايرانيه
رافقتها اضطرابات طلابيه في نحو 50 جامعه
وكليه في العاصمه الايرانيه طهران
جاءت المدن الكرديه في المقدمه وتحديدا
مدينه مهابات في اذربيجان الغربيه التي
تعرضت خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه الى هجوم مكثف
من قبل القوات الامنيه والعسكريه بالاسلحه
الثقيله وقطع الكهرباء ورغم القمع الذي
تتهم قوه الامن والقوات الخاصه والبازيد
بممارسته
الا ان سكان هذه المدينه خرجوا للشوارع
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى للمشاركه في
الاحتجاجات اما الجامعات الايرانيه
فاستجابت لدعوات الاضطراب الطلبه نظموا
مسيرات احتجاجيه في 50 جامعه وكليه ومعهدا
تقريبا شملت خمس جامعات كبرى في طهران نظم
فيها اكبر تجمع احتجاج للطلاب تحديدا في
جامعه تبريز للعلوم الطبيه وجامعه بهجت في
طهران بالاضافه الى جامعه كردستان وجامعه
القدس التي شهدت اعنف هجوم من قبل القوات
الامنيه
نتج عنه اصابه عدد كبير من الطلبه بجروح
خطيره واعتقاله عدد اخر منهم وقد قتل احد
طلابها ويدعى حميد رضا روحي والذي تحول
جنازته في مقبره بهج زهراء الى تجمع
احتجاج جديد سلطان العربيه
السيد وجدان عبد الرحمن مرحبا بك سيد
وجدان لنشره الخامسه على شاشه العربيه نحن
نتحدث ربما عن لحظه الفارقه يعني هناك دفع
باسلحه ثقيله بتعزيزات العسكريه بتحليق
ايضا
للطيران او الجيش وتدخل بشكل مباشر في قمع
هذه الاحتجاجات الى اين يقضنا هذا المشهد
تحياتي لك يا استاذه رشا ولا متابعيكي
الكرام لا شك انه النظام الايراني بما انه
يعرف تماما بانه شالله الاحتجاجات انطلقت
من كردستان وما زالت هذه الشعله بشكل كبير
والتسع ساعات
لكل مختلف المدن في المناطق الكرديه وايضا
في داخل المدن الايرانيه من الجامعات
وايضا المدارس لذلك انه يحاول همم التركيز
على نقطه الاشتعال لاخمادها لكن ما
شاهدناهم وكل ما قام بقمع المحتاجين كما
اا كل ما شاهدناه هنالك ردت فعله كبيره
وواسعه وخيره دليل احتجاجات صباح هذا
اليوم في المناطق الكرديه تعامل الحرس
الثوري الايراني بوحشيه ليله البارحه لكن
هذا لا لم يخيف الشارع الكردي وانما شاهد
ان هناك حراك كبير
وواسع في مختلف المدن الكرديه وكانت هنالك
التاريخيه
من سيدافع عن هؤلاء المحتاجين اذا
اااه
الحارس الثوري الايراني يحاول استخدام همم
السلاح الثقيل لقمع الاحتجاجات ولكنه ااه
المدن هي فيها العدد السكاني كبير ملايين
من همم المواطنين في داخل المدن ولا يمكن
ان تكون هذه هي المدينه برمتها يتم
تدميرها من خلال همم الاليات العسكريه همم
لذلك لانه الشارع يخرج حينما تكون هنالك
العاليات العسكريه في منطقه معين ستخرج
هنالك احتجاجات في مناطق همم اخرى لذلك
هذا ايضا ينهيك القوات الحرس الثوري لانها
كانت همم تدخلت القوات الشرطه وقوات الامن
لكنها فشلت في قام همم احتجاجات ولذلك
الفرصه السابقه
حرب الشوارع
نعم هذا ايييه هذا ما
اعتقد نصل اليه لان
الحرس الثوري الايراني تدخل بعد فشل
القوات الامنيه والجيش تدخل الحرس ولذلك
اتى بالاليات العسكريه لكن المشكله انه
ايران بايران جغرافيا كبيره وواسعه لا
يمكن ان يتدخل لكل المناطق بهذه القوى رغم
انه يحاول من خلال هذه
الاليات قبل هذه الاحتجاجات لكن نشهد انه
حراك في مناطق هو مدن اخرى
من استخدام الاله العسكريه الحاده او
العنيفه بهذه الصوره
همم للاسف هذا النظام هو النظام قمعي
وايضا الحرس الثوري الايراني هو في الاساس
تاسس واسم الحرس هو اا الحرس الثوري
الايراني لحفظ النظام ما يهم الحرس الثوري
الايراني هو حفظ النظام لا يراعي لا مساله
همم المواطن ولا حقوق المواطنه ولا على
شعب تركيزه هو فقط حفظ النظام لذلك هذه
السلاحيه من اجل حفظ النظام وليس من اجل
الدفاع عن الشاعر عبد الرحمن
ايرانيه من لندن تحياتي
ونتابع مع حضراتكم هذه اللقطات التي
وصلتنا قبل قليل لاطلاق الامن الايراني ان
نرى على المحتجين في مدينه مهابات
[موسيقى]
وفي تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه افادم الرسول
العربيه بان القوات الروسيه تواصل قصف
مدينه بخموت التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاوكراني وتعد بخموط محورا استراتيجيا
كونها قريبه من مدينه سفيانسك التي تحتوي
او تحوي محطات التقنيه المياه على نهر
سيبر سيكيدوناست وتسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه
في غضون ذلك دعى المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للتقدريه رافاييل روسي الى وقف
فوري للهجمات بالقرب من محطه زبرجيا ناويه
ايا كان الطرف الذي قام بالقصر واشار روسي
الى رصد انفجارات قريبه وقويه بالقرب من
محطه زاباروجيناويه مساء امس وصبح اليوم
من بينها 10 انفجارات اليوم فقط واصفا
الوضع بالمحطه بانه مروع للغايه من ذاته
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان القذافي
اوكرانيا استهدفت خطوط الطاقه بمحطه
النوويه واشارت الى تقييم حجم الاضرار بعد
زياره الميدانيه بالمشاركه مع ورد من
وكاله التقدريا بينما اتهمت الهيئه
المشغله للطاقه الاوكرانيه اتهمت روسيا
بقصف محطه زبرجيا النوويه
سياسيا اكد رئيس الاوكرانيه
للمسؤولين الغربيين ان انهاء الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا لن يكون ضمانه
للسلام وان اليهودنا مع روسيا ستزيد الوضع
سوءا
تقتربوا الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا من
شهرها التاسع الا ان المخاض لا يبدو قريبا
فالطرفاني لا يقتربان من وضع حد لاول حرب
في اوروبا منذ عقود
بالرغم من التصريحات الروسيه التي لا
تمانع مفاوضات السلام يبدو الطرف
الاوكراني فاقدا للثقه بجاره الشرقيه
وترفض كيف ان ترى الهدنه القصيره خطوه نحو
انهاء الحرب بل تنظر اليها كف فرصه تختنها
روسيا استعاده قواها بعد الخسائر التي
منيت بها عقب استعاده القوات الاخرانيه
السياده على بعض المناطق كخرسون رشا
تبحث روسيا الان عن هدنه قصيره وفتره راحه
لاستعاده القوه قد يسمي شخص ما هذا نهايه
الحرب لكن مثل هذه المهله لن تؤدي الا الى
تفاقم الوضع كيف وبعد استغلالها نقاط ضعف
روسيا اشترطت على موسكو سحب قوتها من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه مقابل الانخراط في مفا
ليسلام اما الحليفه واشنطن ترفض اي نوع من
الضغط يدفع اوكرانيا نحو الحوار
شروط اعتبرتها موسكو غير واقعيه متهمه كيف
بالتسويف السلام في ظل المعطيات يبدو افق
الازمه الاوكرانيه الضبابيا لكن اوكرانيا
ترسم توقعات معاكسه
[موسيقى]
مخاوي فوق اوكرانيا من هدنه او مفاوضات
السلامه عززتها تصريحات واشنطن على لسان
جيك سوليفان مستشار الامن القومي الذي ربط
خيار وقف كياب للقتال بنهايه اوكرانيا
الملياردير الامريكيه الماسكي يغرد تويتر
على قيد الحياه
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد عامين من حضره ترامب
من منصه تويتر يعود الموقع بملك جديد يسمح
لترامب بتغريد مجددا وخلال دقائق تويتر
الغى حظر الملف الشخصي للرئيس السابق على
المنصه ولكن الواقع يخالف التوقعات فقد
قالت ترامب انه لا يرى اي سبب للعوده الى
تويتر وسبب كما عزاء بان تويتر يعاني من
مشكلات كثيره ولا يصدق ذاهبا الى ابعد من
ذلك بالقول ان حسابات المنصه معظمها مزيفه
تصريحات ترامب هذه تاتي بعد ان استفتاء
مالك منصه الى ماسك جمهوره تويتر في عوده
ترامب الاستفتاء وشارك به اكثر من 15
مليون مستخدم ما يؤكده دعم الملايين لطرح
وعوده التمر حيث وصلت نسبه الدعم اكثر من
واحد
55% لي بذلك الجمهور بقاء ترامب ويعلنها
ماسك ترامب نفسه تفاعل مع الاستفتاء
بطريقه اخرى فقد قال للمستخدمين انتم
صوتتم بايجابيه ولكن لا تقلقوا لن اذهب
الى مكان بعيد وهنا تبدو المفارقه ان
ترامب تحدث عن منصاته سوشيال توت وصفا
اياها بالمميزه وهي المنصه التي اطلقها
بعض حظره من تويتر
وخلال دقائق من عوده تفعيل حساب على تويتر
ارتفع اعداد متابعي الرئيس السابق بشكل
قياسي بعد ان حضر لنحو سنتين اثر اقتحمي
انصاره مبنى كبتل في واشنطن في يناير 20
21 مراقبه سريعه للحساب الذي اعاد مالك
المنصه الجديده الى ماسك احياءهم قبل
ساعات اظهرت ارتفاعا كبيرا ارتفاعا وصل
الى
734,000 حتى كتابتها هذا الخبر
[موسيقى]
واستمرار لازم
على تويتر وكتب ان المنصه لا تزال حيه
وتاتي تغريده ماسك فيما افادت وكاله
بلومبيرج ان مالك سويتر يفكر في تسريح
مزيد من الموظفين بقسم المبيعات بالشركه
بعد يوم غدا الاثنين وكذلك في ظل مخاوف من
حدوث انقطاع في الخدمه خلال الايام
المقبله وتحذيرات من خبراء من انهيار
المنصه
ومن قلب الحدث من سان فرانسيسكو ينضم
الينا زميلي حسين الطود مراسل العربيه
مرحبا بك حسين دعنا في الصوره يبدو ان
الاعداد
ستتزايد هناك تسريح لعدد اخر من الموظفين
هناك مخاوف كبيره تجتاح العالم الحكومات
السفارات المستخدمين كيف سيكون الوضع
بالنسبه لتويتر خلال الساعات القليله
المقبله
صباح الخير رشا بالفعل اليوم وفي الحقيقه
كما يقول المراقبون الان هو يوم اختبار
يوم سيبدا كاس العالم من المرجح بحسب
الكثيرين من خبراء التقنيه تقريبا 50% همم
يفشل تقدر ان يحدث قطاعات بسبب نقص الحاصل
الان بالموظفين التقنيين والمهندسين عن
صيانه الموقع
والتاكد من استمريته من ثيابيه بالنسبه
للتسريحات التسريحات الموظفين هناك من
يشير الى تضارب الان داخل المؤسسه مؤسس
تويتر التي تظهر خلفي همم هنا في سان
فرانسيسكو بان لهم ماسك يطلب من الموظفين
همم
الاستقاله البقاء والعمل لساعات طويله
وبتفاني ثم يرسل همم بريد الكترونيين يطلب
من البعض البقاء والاجتماع معه كما حصل
اليوم الجمعه عندما طلب من من يجيد
البرمجه بان يجتمع معه هنا والان لا نسمع
من خلال بانه سيتم تسريح عدد اخر من
الموظفين هنا كمان يشير الى تضارب في
قرارات مصر في الايام الاخيره همم سبب همم
الوضعيه التي يمر بها تويتر الان وبسبب
المشاكل التي التقنيه التي قد يواجهها همم
بالنسبه ايضا فقط تذكر بالنسبه لدونالد
ترامب دونالد ترامب هنا كمان يقول انه
مفاجئ الجميع لكن في الحقيقه هو كان له
موقف صادق بانه لن يعود الى تويتر عندما
اشترى له ماسك همم منصه همم في شهر اكتوبر
الماضي
ولكن حسين هل استطعت الوصول لبعض الموظفين
والعاملين داخل تويتر لنقل الصوره من داخل
الشركه ما الذي يحدث
البارحه رشا كنا رصدنا ودخول بعض الاشخاص
الى موقع الشركه الى مدخل الشركه تحولنا
اللحاق بهم ولكن الامن همم المسؤول عنها
طلب منها الابتعاد والبقاء الخارج سياصير
مع المصور فقط لاريكم هذا هو تويتر الان
ااه هذا هو المبنى هذه الاشاره
الشهيره له همم في على يمين همم الشاشه
يكون المدخل الرئيسي هنا هناك همم البارحه
عندما حاولنا همم الاقتراب في ساعات
الصباح الاولى استطعنا ان ندخل حتى المدخل
الرئيسي همم في الداخل ولكن في همم في
ساعات الظهر عندما شاهدنا بعض الاشخاص
يدخلون لا نعرف الحقيقه ان كانوا همم
موظفين ام لا ولكن حاولنا اللحاق بهم
لنسالهم عن ما يجري يتكلم موظفين مع ما
يواجهونه لكن تدخل هنا همم جهاز الامني
همم شركه تويتر فطلب منك قالوا لنا هذه
هذه ملكيه خاصه الرجاء البقاء في الخارج
وعدم الدخول الى همم حرم المكان هذان
المبنيان رشا هما تابعا لتويتر يعني لديها
القسم الاكبر تلك هي العلامه هذا المبنى
الاخر وهذا المبنى هنا ايضا همم مؤسسه
لكاميرا العربيه ومراس العربيه الزمير
حسين الطوب من سان فرانسيسكو مقرات شركه
تويتر الزميل حسين يرصد لنا بالصوره
الواقع في محيط هذه الشركات حسين تتحدث عن
دخول الموظفين او اعداد منهم الى الداخل
لكن الامن لا يسمح لوسائل الاعلام بالتحدث
معهم ولكن هذه صور خاصه وحصريه لنا من
مقررات شركه تويتر في سان فرانسيسكو تفضل
حسين
نعم صار احاول ان نقترب الان لنرى ان كان
كنا سا نستطيع الدخول ام انهم سيطلبوا منا
المغادره مره اخرى
كما حصل البارح
هذا هو احد المداخل الرئيسيه هذان
المبنيان رشا
ساقترب اكثر همم من المبنى من المدخل
الرئيسي
كما ترين طبعا هنا هنا يوجد عدد من
المحلات الاخرى همم المتاجر الاخرى ولكن
التويتر موجود في الطوابق العليا
نعم
المدخل الرئيسي
الدخول اكثر هذا هو هذا هو المكتب اذا
رايت العلامه من هنا يصعدون الى الطوابق
العليا للشركه حيث اجتمع ماس منذ يومين مع
عدد من الموظفين حيث راينا الموظفين كانوا
في الداخل اذا ممكن كانوا في الداخل
يتحدثون الى احد رجال الامن المسؤول عن
الشركه ثم تتدخل رجل
الاعلى هذا فقط هو المدخل العمل في
الطوابق الاعلى هذا فقط والمدخل هذا هذا
نعم هذا هذا في هذا المبنى هناك كما قلت
هناك مبنيان العمل يتم في الطوابق العليا
حسب ما شرح لنا هنا همم
المسؤولون في عن ايه
عن عن المباني
تتحدثنا الى بعضهم من البارحه قالوا انه
متى شركه تويتر موجوده في الطوابق العليا
يتم الدخول اليها من هذا الباب ومن باب
اخر ولكن هذا هو الباب الرئيسي همم الشركه
وكما ترعين العلامه موجوده هناك من يريد
ان يدخل الى الشركه عليها ان يدخل من هذا
الباب ثم يصعد في المصعد الى الطوابق
العليا وهي هناك اكثر من طابق لشركه
تويوتا حسب ما فهمنا من بعض العاملين هنا
في هذه
العمارات هذه الابنيه هذه
طبعا يجب ان نذكر اننا ان ان اليوم الاحد
الساعه 8:00 نزلنا الان على الساعه
السادسه والاربعين دقيقه صباحا نتوقع غدا
ان يكون هناك قدوم اكيد للموظفين سنرصدها
بطبيعه الحال منذ ساعات صباح الاولى
لشاشه العربيه زميلي حسين الطوب من سان
فرانسيسكو شكرا لك وكانت هذه صور خاصه
لمقرات تويتر في مدينه سان فرانسيسكو صور
خاصه لكاميرا العربي العربيه
والان الى اخبار الرياضه مع زميلتي لليان
تنوري سنبقى معك طول طوال هذا الشهر اخبار
رياضه ستتصدر كل شيء لا احد سيتابع شيء
اسمه كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
في الشرق الاوسط والعالم العربي وسط حضور
قاده العالم وكبر الشخصيات من المدعوين
ستكون رساله الحفل بمثابه دعوه الى العالم
اجمال الحضور الى قطر وتتمحور حول التقارب
بين كل الشعوب وتغلب على الاختلافات من
خلال الانسانيه والاحترام والشموليه اوضح
للتحدي الدولي لكره القدم في بيان له ان
مفاجاه عديده بانتظار الجماهير كره القدم
حول العالم بهذا الحفل
وكان صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء قد وصل
الى قطر اليوم تلبيه لدعوه اخيه صاحب
السمو الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني امير
دوله قطر لحضور حفل افتتاح بطوله كاس
العالم
في عام 2010 احتفلت قطر بفوزها بحق
استضافه هذه البطوله استضافه اولى ومشاركه
اولى لمنتخب بها
اول منتخب منذ ايطاليا عام 34 يشارك في
النهائيات كمستضيف دون ان يسبقاله التاهل
منتخب قطر بلا خبره موندياليه على مستوى
المنتخب الاول لكن ذاكره العنابي تحتفظ
بمغامره الموندياليه تاريخيه كانت على
مستوى منتخب الشباب عام 1981
تاهل المنتخب القطري ثانيا في المجموعات
خلف الاورغواي وعلى حساب بولندا وامريكا
ثم اقصى البرازيل في ربع النهائي بثلاثه
الاثنين وان انجلترا في نصف النهائي
بهدفين بهدف قبل ان يخسر المباراه
النهائيه امام المانيا الغربيه
[موسيقى]
بعد 40 عاما سيظهر ابناء ذلك الجيل في
المونديال هذه المره في بلادهم التي
ستحتضن كاس العالم بعد ان مر فريقهم برحله
طويله من التجهيز اذ عمل المدرب سانشيز في
اكاديميه اسباير منذ 2006 قبل ان يتولى
تدريب منتخب الشباب في 2013 ثم الاولمبي
في 2017 وبعد ذلك تدريب المنتخب الاول
الذي تولى مسؤوليته بعد التاكد من خروج
الفريق من تصفيات مونديال 2018
[موسيقى]
قرر نتيجه الشون مدرب فرنسا عدم استدعاء
لاعب بديل لكريم بنزيما الذي اجبرته
الاصابه على مغادره قائمه المونديال حيث
تجددت معاناته مع الاصابه بتمزق في عضله
الفخذ الايسر خلال التدريبات مساء امس
السبت وكان اللاعب البالغ من العمر 34
عاما يحلم بقياده منتخب بلاده للفوز بكاس
العالم بعد ما غاب عن صفوفه في مونديال
اقل من ساعه تفصلنا عن انطلاق منافسات
البطوله بمشاركه 32 منتخبا ونخبه من نجوم
الكره العالميه ولكن اعلم انه في الختام
سيكون البطل واحد يا ترى على من تصب
ترشيحات
البرازيل صاحبه الخمسه نجوم ما زالت تطمح
بالمزيد من البريق وهي مرشحه فوق العاده
للظفر باللقب
المانيا قد تبدو غير مرشح لكنها مرشحه
وبقوه وكانها عاده الالمان والا كيف نصعد
قميصها باربعه نجوم
حامله اللقب فرنسا
في دوري الامم الاوروبيه بعجوبه
فرنسا على حقيقتها كمرشح للفوز باللقب
الارجنتين وبعد الاحتفالات بالفوز بكوبا
امريكا هل سيثبت ليونيل ميسي انه قادر على
السير على خطى مارادونا واهداء الارجنتين
لقبا عالميا غائبا منذ سنوات خلاف
يقولون لكل امرئ من اسمه نصيب الاسود
الثلاثه المنتخب الانجليزي خالفت تلك
المقوله ففراسه لا تتعدى كاسا واحدا حصدها
عام 66 فهل سيكون كاس العالم قطر موسم
الصيد للاسود الثلاثه بقياده ساوث كيك
وانتهاء سنوات عجاف
اسبانيا بيجيل من الشباب ومدرب الشعب هل
ستقول كلمتها في مونديال قطر
هولندا صاحبه اسوء حظ مونديال على الاطلاق
هل ستفعلها وتعاند الحظ قبل ان يعاندها
وتظهر باللقب وتتخلى عن لاعب دوري الوسيط
الذي مارسته طويلا
البرتغال هل ستتاهل مع سيدات كريستيانو
رونالدو في مجموعته السابق وتذهب بعيدا
لتعانقب لاول مره في تاريخها
بلجيكا
ايضا ان تقارح الكبار وتعلق نجمتها الاولى
ومن سنفتقدهم هناك بالمقابل لاعبون الشباب
يطيلون بموهبتهم نبقى اعيننا عليهم
ونرصدهم من خلال الاجتهادهم وتالقهم ما
عنديتهم
النسخه الثانيه والعشرون فيها فقط كبار
اللعبه مثل رونالدو وميسي حتى الانظار
هناك مواهب صاعده تسعى لاثبات نفسها في
اكبر محفل دولي
ابرزها اوريليانت شاومي نيه لاعب ريال
مدريد من بين الاسماء اللامعه في المنتخب
الفرنسي وسيكون مفتاحها وسط الديوك
في انجلترا
احد المواهب البارزه التي تتنافس عليه
الانديه في القاره العجوز لخطف لاعب
بروسيا دورتموند
في اسبانيا وبعد انفرد نفسه في برشلونه
يعمل بان يقدمه مستويات كبيره في خط وسط
منتخب الماتور الذي يعرف وجود زميله بيدري
الماكينات الالمانيه تعول على النجم
الصاعد جمال موسيالا المتالقي في بايرن
ميونخ كما يعتبر يوسف موكوكو احد مفاجات
قائمتهالك في سن السابعه عشر نجم بروسيا
دورتموند قد يكون افضل بديل للمصاب
فينيسيوس وبعد ان قاد ريال مدريد للفوز
بذات الاذنين سيقود خطا هجوم البرازيل
الذي يعرف ايضا وجود انتونيا المنضم
لمانشستر يونايتد في صفقه القياسيه
اليوم يوجد في قائمه فرناندو سانتوس وسيكل
برفقه رونالدو سيلفا ثلاثيا مرعبا في
الهجوم
فخور سعيد اني راح يشارك في كاس العالم
هيشا اكيد مثل ما قلت انت وحلمت الطفوله
حاولنا في مرات سابقه للوصول عن طريق
تصفيات لكن
ما نجحنا الحين احنا موجودين في كاس
العالم
وانا متاكد لو ان شاركنا في تصفيات اللي
فاتت كنا راح انتهى لكاس العالم همم اكيد
همم
شعور لا يوصف صراحه ما عندي كلمات اقدر
اعبر فيها عن همم عن نفسي اني انا راح
اكون موجود همم في هذا البطوله في خلاف
الاسامي اللي قلتها
بامكانيات كبيره هو يمكنهم التطور بشكل
كبير والوصول الى افضل المستويات مع مرور
مباريات البطوله في الاكوادور تطورت بشكل
كبير في الفتره الماضيه
ولدينا كثير من اللاعبين في اوروبا
توقع نجم الكره الالمانيه سابقا نوردين
جريزمان بطوله كاس عالم مليئه بالمفاجات
تصريحات بليز من جاءت في مؤتمر صحفي في
الدوحه اعتبر فيه بان النسخه الحاليه قد
تشهد مفاجات كثيره من قبل منتخبات غير
مرشحه ربما يكون منتخبا افريقيا او اسيا
اذا كان يتمتع بالشجاعه فربما يستطيع
الذهاب بعيدا في هذه البطوله على حد
تعبيره اشارك لزما الا انا منتخبات التي
تعتمد اسلوبا ديفاعيا بحثا لن تستطيع
الذهاب بعيدا في المنافسه
تغير بقى رومي لولوكوا عن تدريبات منتخب
بلجيكا اليوم قبل ثلاثه ايام من مباراه
الاولى الاربعاء المقبل ضمن المجموعه
السادسه على لوكاكو من اصابه في اوتار
الركبه نهايه اكتوبر بعد ان عاد قبلها من
اصابه حرمته من اللاعب لمده شهرين واختار
مدرب بلجيكا روبرتو مارتينيز لوكاكو في
قائمه بلجيكا التي تلعب مع كندا اولا ثم
المغرب وتختتم دور المجموعات امام كرواتيا
اجت كاميرون اول حصه تدريبيه لها في
الدوحه اليوم في اطار التحضيرات ضمن
منافسات المجموعه السابعه لكاس العالم
الكاميرون تواجه سويسرا في مباراتها
الافتتاحيه للمجموعه السابعه من الرابع
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري ثم تواجه صربي
بعد اربعه ايام قبل ان تختم مرحله
المجموعات ضد البرازيل في الثاني من
ديسمبر
وتدرب منتخب البرتغال بكامل النجومه في
الدوحه بينما يواصل فريق استعداداته لبدء
مشاركته في البطوله البرتغال تفتتح
مشوارها امام غانا يوم الخميس المقبل ثم
تواجه فريق المدرب فرناندو سانتوس نظيره
الاوروغوياني بعدها باربعه ايام قبل ان
يختتم مرحله المجموعات ضد كوريا الجنوبيه
يوم الجمعه في الثاني من ديسمبر
اعترف مدافع كرواتيا
السابق في ليفربول محمد صلاح يشعر بالغيره
من مشاركته في كاس العالم
انا متريبها
محمد صلاح يشعر بالغيره لانني اتواجد بكاس
العالم حيث كنت ساشعر بالغيره ايضا لو حدث
العكس صلاح اخبرني انه سيقوم بتشجيعي ومن
الجيد سماع ذلك ولاكون صريحا انا حزين
لانه لم يتاهل لقد كان قريبا جدا من
التاهل ولكن للاسف كان مني افضل والاكثر
حسما
نهايه اخبار الرياضه
قلت مؤمني مؤمني صحيح ههه شكرا
للمره الاولى شارك السفينه دوريه بريطانيه
في مناورات عسكريه اعتياديه لسلاح حي
البحريه الياباني والامريكي في المحيط
الهادئ على ما ذكرت سلطات البريطانيه
وانضمت سفينه البريطانيه الى المناورات
التي استمرت 10 ايام وركزت على الاستجابه
المشتركه لهجمات المسلحه بهدف اختبار
جاهزيه الدول المشاركه
وتنضم الينا من طوكيو مفاده العربيه
الجميله ميسون وهد للاطلاع على تفاصيل هذه
المناورات مرحبا بك ميسون ضعينا في صوره
حول هذه المناورات ومشاركه سفن بريطانيه
فيها
اهلا بك يا رشا هذه المناورات المعروفه
بكينسورد شارك فيها تقريبا 36 الف عسكري
وايضا 30 سفينه وايضا 370 طائره هذه
المناورات هي اعتياديه بدات منذ عام 1985
هذه التمارين هي السادسه عشره هذه السنه
هي تمارين اعتياديه ولكن لها اهميه كبرى
هذه المره نظرا للتوترات والتصعيد من قبل
كوريا الشماليه همم بدات هذه المناورات
وكما ذكر الخبر استمرت 10 ايام شاركت فيها
الولايات المتحده الامم البريطانيا وايضا
اليابان بالاضافه الى كندا
وكان ال- همم الهدف من هذه المناورات حسب
هذه الدول والمسؤوليه فيها
ليتاكدوا من السيناريوهات وهي كانت
سيناريوهات جديه
كانها حقيقيه من اجل التاكد بانه هناك
تنسيق كامل بين هذه الدول لمواجهه
التعديلات كوريا
كيف تنعكس هذه المخاوف على الشارع في
اليابان انت موجوده في العاصمه وتتابعين
هل هناك مخاوف بالفعل من ان تكون هناك
تهديدات كوريه شماليه لليابان
لحسب ما نحن تابعنا منذ يومين ونحن هنا في
اليابان وطبعا كنا فيه طوكيو نتجول بين
الناس الحقيقه ان الحياه الطبيعيه جدا
يعني حتى تقاطع شيبويا المعروف عنه بانه
كل دقيقه يمر عبره هو بين 1000 و2,000 شخص
ايضا ما زال كما هو
والعالم تعيش حياه طبيعيه ليس هناك من
يتحدث عن هذا الامر ليس هناك من مخاوف
نظرا طبعا دي التطمينات التي دائما تقدمها
حكومه اليابان
لمواطنيها وكان ايضا رئيس الوزراء
الياباني تحدث عن الاطلاق الاخير للصاروخ
البلاستيك بعيد المدى الذي اطلقته كوريا
الشماليه وقال بانه استفزاز غير مقبول
واكد انه سقط في المياه الاقتصاديه
لاليابان ولكن ليس هناك من اضرار اما
الاهم الان رشا منذ قليل كنا معكم
اا الفقره الرياضيه الكل الان مهتم
وبانتظار في بدايه كاس العالم بعد ساعه
حيث ستلعب اليابان نهار الاربعاء ضد
المنتخب
انت تحبين الرياضه وتتابعين الرياضه
كبير نعم زميلتي المفضله العربيه من طوكيو
شكرا لك
ولمتابعه ملفات العربيه ابقوا معنا دائما
على شاشه العربيه خدمه الاخباريه مستمره
يمكنكم ايضا زياره موقع العربيه لمتابعه
اخر التطورات وسنلتقي بعد قليل في خدمه
اخباريه وسنتابع معكم بالطبع حفل الافتتاح
مونديال قطر 20 22 الى اللقاء